- But do y'all know each other.
- [Josh] Yeah.
- Yeah. We, I got invited
to do a little workout
with Laird Hamilton, you
know, Laird Hamilton.
He's the hundred foot
big wave, crazy surfer.
And he says, hey, I saw
him on the beach one time
and he goes, "Hey, come up
and come work out with me.".
So I go to his house up in mountain-
- Do dudes do that a
lot? Y'all are just like,
"Hey, come work out with me."?
- Yeah, that's all we do, actually.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] Wow!
- Yeah, that's it
- [Tony] That's what do.
- So glad I'm a woman right now (laughs).
- But he's got this pool
and it's custom-made
for these workouts, these
underwater workouts with weights.
And so I go up there
and I jump in the pool
and I see him coming out and he's shredded
and I'm like, "Well, this is a
pretty cool little workout.".
And I start to do the workout
and you're underwater.
- You're panicking.
- And you can't breathe.
- You're oh, you're not doing
it in your heads above water.
You're underwater.
- No underwater, and Laird,
he surfs hundred foot waves.
He's crazy. He's like,
"Hey, go do a workout,
get underneath the water.
Then you're gonna go
to the ice cold tub.",
which just filled with ice.
- Those are good for you.
- And then from there, you go
to 180 degree sauna and you
do a bike for 20 minutes.
And I'm like, I almost die.
- I was like, what does your
heart do during this? Yeah.
- But he does it all the time.
- Yeah. But what's
great is you look at him
and you go, no, like
this guy's gonna show up
and he's gonna control the whole pool.
And he got there and
he started crying and-
(everyone laughs)
- One of the worst things
I ever did in my life.
I was like
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- I slept like a baby
- You did great, you did great.
- Oh my God, this reminds
me. It was one time,
they were like my friends on a vacation,
they're like, "We're gonna
go on this beautiful hike.",
and I was like, hell yeah, let's do it.
[Josh] Yeah.
- It was like fat camp from hell.
(Josh and audience laugh)
It was, I literally, my
stomach got upset. I was like,
oh my, I was like, it was the
worst experience of my life.
[Josh And Tony] Yeah.
And that's why I don't work out.